[Music]
Joe Biden's hit rock bottom it's not
because of his latest train wreck
approval numbers or his stumble kamla is
now more popular than Joe Biden the
approval rating of our word salad
spewing VP is at
35% which is a hair better than her boss
who clocks in at
34% it's no wonder our Veep has had a
little extra spring in her step looks
like she had a pretty good time at
Howard University celebration bowl
game vice president of the United States
kamla Harris but also a very proud
graduate of Howard University very proud
bison here to cheer on my team I say our
team when she's around can I say our
team I don't know about all of that and
as Joe B bottoms out a new report claims
that his AIDS are worried about his age
and energy levels but Dr Jill has the
prescription to get his Mojo going again
it's not that the first lady trying to
get her husband to eat better rest more
and travel less she is very involved in
making sure that he gets enough rest
she's also been pushing him on his diet
trying to get him to eat more fish um
and and salmon and a little bit less
junk food what less junk food all right
uh Dana Joe just took a 4 Day weekend um
but he really wants to travel more I'm
not sure how he could travel less I mean
perhaps if he doesn't take the 30 second
commute from the East Wing to The West
Wing he could cut down on some travel I
don't I don't get this actually because
something's
happening I think that the White House
has realized that his numbers are
solidifying in the 30s in the low 30s
and once you get to that point it's very
hard to get out of it it's also possible
that the White House and campaign team
has specifically put this into the news
cycle to give a heads up to the donors
and the party faithful to say look we
got it we're working on it no problem or
there are now leaks within a very tight
white house but I think it's the former
I think that they want everyone to know
that Dr Jill is on it she's going to
make sure that he's okay and that he can
go the distance the thing about KLA
Harris is that perhaps her 17th staff
turnover and makeover has finally like
helped a little bit I mean that might
that might be the case um he is in
pretty bad shape this image of him is
solidifying in the people's mind and
when you get to that point it's hard to
break apart
concrete Katie do you think it's kamla's
rise or Joe's descent that's created
this imbalance I don't think she's
really Rising they're both in the low
30s and this is this poll is actually
kind of an outlier she's usually like in
the high 20s even lower 30s uh in terms
of her approval but the bottom line is
like they have a they're going to have a
very hard time over the next year trying
to change the realities of what is
making them unpopular so they keep
trying trying to say inflation is going
down but don't worry the inflation
reduction act which isn't working is
working to fix this problem they're not
going to get some big legislative deal
over the next year that they can really
run on and and to win and so now they're
turning to things again like don't worry
we're working on junk fees uh people
don't like junk fees but they don't like
high prices at the grocery store even
more and so they're running out of
options in terms of turning the boat
around for big accomplishments just
based on the makeup of what's happening
on Capitol Hill and the issues that are
plaguing them that take time to turn
around and a reversal of a number of
policies that they've been championing
over the last three years Harold do you
agree that it's too late for the White
House to turn things around I don't
think it's too late I don't dismiss
these numbers I don't dismiss or
belittle the fact that the White House
as I shared last week and we've talked
about I don't think that there's a uh if
there is a strategy I don't know what it
is um and it seems to me that one of the
things that you would want to be talking
about Dana knows this as well as any um
is summing up your achievements and
saying how your achievements are going
to help you accomplish even more over
the next four years I could write one
here they don't need to listen to me but
I I'd say we're building more things in
America including chips and
refrigerators and cars and prescription
drugs so we don't have to be dependent
on others two we invest in our
infrastructure and even Republicans and
de some I don't think any Democrat
didn't vote for but people who didn't
vote for the bill are bragging about it
when money comes to their districts
we're protecting Women's Health rights
inflation is coming down unemployment is
at record lows and the stock market
seems seems to be setting record highs
they could say it a little more
passionately and for that matter repeat
it over and over and over again and say
if I'm given four more years this is
what I would do um if you just sit back
and you just look at these numbers and
you talk about things that not relevant
to the American people the numbers are
going to continue to persist what Harold
seems to be saying is that Hunter should
give his dad a line of
cocaine that's exactly what Harold was
saying yes it is weird though when you
mention all those metrics how why is
isn't it translating in people's lives
something's going on that we don't know
KLA Harris more popular than Joe Biden
that's not saying much right here are
three things that are more popular than
Joe Biden Gang Green getting hit in the
face with a hammer and Brian
kilme but you mentioned this to to Katie
kamla has been playing the long game she
didn't have to improve she knows that
even if she stays put Joe would degrade
like an avoc sliced avocado in the sun
it's like why I hang out with Dana I
look taller cuz she's shorter she comma
fail fails up every time Joe falls down
she's like the dumb student who gets by
because the teacher grades on a curve
but there's only two people in the class
and one of them you know it's breakfast
is in bombing fluid he can't rest
anymore unless he checks into Forest
Lawn but the big question is who if they
unload Joe and I think they will who
gets kamla it's like when a couple
splits up who gets the cat except no one
wants the cat they need to have a a
rescue shelter for politicians because
she can't stay on the ticket with or
without Joe she only has one fan and
that's Dan Quail saying thank you thank
you wait a second they wouldn't Jam
kamla onto a ticket with Gavin Nome
you're saying oh I don't think so
because that would be an accusation of
racism cat fight yeah we're here for
that they're also both from the same
state so I'm not sure that they could
but is there a constitutional argument
because I really don't
care coming up Eric Adams just said
something about New York City that will
shock you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else